il y a des choses de toute façon on a
effectivement qu'on ne peut pas montrer
vous savez on appelle l'armée la grande
muette la pénitentiaire la petite muette
les choses peuvent pas sortir il y a une
espèce d'omerta comme ça et culte du
secret les questions sont pratiquement
préparées à l'avance les détenus qui
interrogent sont triés à l'avance tout
ce que vous pouvez dire un visage
couvert c'est comme si vous ne dites NON
comme un chien même je crois même les
chiens sont mieux très technique ils ont
tout filmé tout ce que nous avec nos
caméras journalistes nous ne pouvons pas
vous montrer
[Applaudissements]
on en séduit de la longueur on est en
hiver tu comprends quelque chose ou quoi
vous avez des rats qui sont aussi gros
que des champs ça c'est notre passe à la
télé il ne donne pas d'autorisation à
des films qui pourraient porter atteinte
à l'image de l'institution mais
reportages étaient totalement négatifs
là encore c'est un peu la schizophrénie
médiatique parfois arrêter d'être
démagos et de vouloir en permanence
critiquer ce qui est fait quoi c'est pas
la réalité qui choque c'est l'image de
la réalité
les détenus qui regardent ça sur leur
petite télé ça les fait pas rêver ça
c'est sûr
[Musique]
la première réflexe on peut avoir c'est
de se dire que
si on entoure
l'atmosphère pénitentiaire d'un mystère
c'est qu'on a quelque chose à cacher ce
n'est pas un problème qui se pose
aujourd'hui s'adapte bien avant l'actuel
direction
40 ans après la prise on continue à
fasciner à indigner à questionner en
France en 2009 plus de 2000 demandes de
reportage en prison ont été accordés un
chiffre en augmentation permanente et
pourtant pourquoi a-t-on l'impression de
ne jamais savoir ce qui se passe
derrière les murs des prisons pourquoi
les journalistes ont-ils tant de mal à
informer sur le milieu carcéral ne
serait-il pas en partie responsable de
la méfiance de l'administration à trop
couvrir ne risque-t-on pas de tomber
dans la prison spectacle finalement les
caméras ont-elles leur place derrière
les barreaux
[Musique]
il est 15h direction tout de suite la
prison de la Santé à Paris ou une prise
d'otage est en cours
7 avril 2010 prison de la Santé à Paris
peu avant midi un détenu prend en otage
son psychiatre pour protester contre ses
conditions de détention
en quelques minutes l'ensemble des
télévisions et radio française se
rassemblent juste en face du bâtiment
malgré le peu d'informations qui filtre
et aucune autre image que celle des murs
de la prison cet événement devient le
feuilleton médiatique de la journée pour
le moment le contact a été établi avec
le détenu mais la prise d'otage est
toujours en cours c'est relativement
rare des prises de ta journée en plus on
est en plein cœur de Paris donc voilà
c'est assez important d'être sur place
rapidement et de suivre l'évolution il y
a quand même quelqu'un qui est pris en
otage quelqu'un qui a menacé par un
prisonnier qui est prévenu pour être
assez dangereux Baptiste où en est-on
quels sont les dernières informations
dont vous disposez et bien ça fait
maintenant 4 heures que Francis dauphin
25 ans condamné à 32 ans de peine de
prison dans 20 ans de peine
incompressible retient en otage un
médecin chef psychiatre ont réussi à
avoir des primes d'informations bien sûr
avec
des syndicalistes
pénitentiaires qui sont à l'intérieur du
bâtiment là donc la prison de la Santé
qui vous donne un peu quelques éléments
ils sont pas très bavards ils nous
disent quand même que c'est calme il
nous donne quelques petits éléments
un petit détail qui nous permettent de
nourrir des papiers
alors là comme vous pouvez le voir on
est bien à l'écart et donc non c'est
pour ça que c'est voilà l'avantage
d'être en direct comme ça les gens
voient qu'on est on est sur place mais
en images plus ronde
finalement après 5h de prise d'otage le
détenu finira par se rendre cet
événement aura placé la prison de la
Santé sous le feu des projecteurs et ce
n'est pas la première fois il y a 10 ans
déjà la santé avait été le théâtre d'un
emballement médiatique sans précédent un
véritable séisme pour la pénitentiaire
[Musique]
le courage tranquille d'une femme
Véronique Vasseur provoque des remous
dans l'administration pénitentiaire
celle-ci a bien du mal à accepter de
reconnaître certaines vérités sur la
vétusté des locaux les violences ou les
oppressions sexuelles dans les prisons
janvier 2000 celle par qui le scandale
arrive s'appelle Véronique Vasseur
médecin chef à la prison de la Santé à
Paris Véronique Vasseur publie le
journal de bord de ses 9 années passées
en milieu carcéral un véritable pavé
dans la mare pénitentiaire les cellules
font 10 mètres carrés et demi et
accueille trois ou quatre détenus les
murs sont de couleur papier kraft avec
une petite ampoule de 60 watts à 3
mètres du sol il suinte de salpêtres la
vermine envahit les matelas moi j'ai eu
un espèce de réflexe à peine rentré
là-dedans de commencer à écrire tous les
jours même sur des bouts de des bouts de
papier n'importe quoi mais décrire pour
pas oublier parce que je me disais c'est
pas vrai quoi c'est pas vrai c'est c'est
un monde totalement à part c'est
inadmissible c'est fou quoi le détenu
est recroquevillé nu dans une mare de
sang au fond du mitard il me chuchote
c'est les gardiens qui m'ont fait ça qui
croient
en fait tout est organisé pour casser
les détenus les briser
le témoignage est si fort que le
quotidien Le Monde décide d'en publier
les bonnes feuilles sur deux pleines
pages l'emballement médiatique est
immédiat
après un week-end de tempête médiatique
Véronique Vasseur retourne à la santé il
y avait la presse il y avait le courrier
qui arrivait qu'il fallait ouvrir avec
des gants en plastique parce qu'il y
avait des menaces et tout il y avait les
flics qui étaient là pour prendre les
empreintes il y avait
les renseignements le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui me demandait de changer
l'itinéraire tous les jours
il y a un moment où je me suis dit quand
est-ce que ça va s'arrêter ces menaces
le médecin n'en connaîtra jamais la
provenance mais si les médias s'emparent
aussi rapidement de la faire c'est parce
que dans son livre Véronique Vasseur
décrit un quotidien qu'aucune caméra n'a
jamais pu filmer les journalistes étant
jusqu'à présent quasi interdit en prison
Dominique Simoneau on a fait
l'expérience en 1991 cette éducatrice
quitte la pénitentiaire pour rejoindre
le journal Libération durant 9 ans elle
tente alors de réaliser des reportages
en milieu carcéral en vain à l'époque
c'était sans doute pire qu'aujourd'hui
c'était
incroyablement compliqué de rentrer en
prison d'ailleurs le livre de Véronique
Vasseur a déclenché l'opération porte
ouverte à la santé une prison qu'on
demandait tous à visiter en tout cas
ceux qui s'intéressaient aux prisons
parmi les journalistes qu'on demandait
tous à visiter depuis je ne sais combien
de temps en réponse au livre de
Véronique Vasseur la ministre de la
Justice de l'époque Élisabeth Guigou
organise en effet une journée portes
ouvertes en prison pour tous les
journalistes qui le demandent et ils ne
vont pas s'en priver
[Musique]
pour un établissement pénitentiaire
français la prison de la Santé a invité
la presse à visiter tous ses bâtiments
aujourd'hui et cela en réponse à un
livre choc le coup était dur
l'institution pénitentiaire se devait de
réagir aujourd'hui les journalistes ont
pu pénétrer là où les difficiles
d'entrer la bouffe elle est dégueulasse
sont dans un état incroyable ces
conditions de détention François Corbère
les connaît bien ce jeune loup de la
droite bordelaise des années 80 est
passé trois fois par la case prison pour
ce romain des lois son surnom qui au
total aura passé près de 25 ans de sa
vie derrière les barreaux ses portes
ouvertes étaient une bénédiction les
journalistes à ce moment-là se ruent
dans la prison filme tout et voit qu'en
fait c'est encore pire
que ce que raconte Véronique Vasseur
d'où alors du point de vue pour
l'administration c'était une faute de
communication
terrible mais pour le public ça a été
une source d'information extraordinaire
parce qu'évidemment tout le monde s'est
emparé du sujet ça a donné beaucoup de
reportages et on a commencé à se dire
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
effectivement dans les prisons
durant plusieurs mois entre 2000 et 2001
le public se passionne pour le problème
carcéral qu'il semble découvrir un
problème pourtant vieux de plusieurs
décennies d'ailleurs dans les semaines
qui suivent un reportage va venir
emboîter le pas au livre de Véronique
Vasseur et enfoncer le clou de la cause
pénitentiaire
c'est un grand document quand vous voyez
spécial vous présente ce soir un
document violent et accablant pour une
démocratie digne de ce nom Benoît Gadret
et journaliste pour France 2 à l'époque
il demande à réaliser pour l'émission
Envoyé Spécial un reportage dans les
prisons Saint-Paul et Saint-Joseph de
Lyon de des établissements les plus
vétustes de France
la combine est connue de tous les
mineurs et tant pis si le gamin les
lèvres mouillées risquent d'être
électrocuté comme il n'y a plus de prise
électrique au mur il n'y a plus non plus
de cloisons un simple drame acculé
d'excréments dissimule une cuvette sans
couvercle
[Musique]
il les avait Guigou Benoît gagnerait
bonsoir madame le ministre d'abord merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation le
producteur Paul Daho et Bernard
Benyamine avait souhaité ne pas en
rester là et il fallait vraiment il y
avait vraiment des questions des
questions à poser au ministre de la
Justice en l'occurrence donc c'était
Elisabeth Guigou votre ministère annoncé
il y a quelques jours le déblocage de
800 millions une enveloppe de 800
millions de francs pour construire trois
nouvelles prisons est-ce que Lyon en
fait partie oui le Premier ministre m'a
accordé donc de pouvoir se lancer la
construction de trois nouvelles prisons
et comme Lyon était en tête des
priorités bien sûr la prison de Lyon
sera incluse dans ce nouveau programme
de trois prisons en voyant ça je pense
que après ce document les choses
forcément devaient évoluer
ce qui n'était pas prévu au départ Lyon
n'était pas une priorité
paradoxalement d'ailleurs il faut pas
que ce soit qu'un feu de paille parce
que en ce moment tout le monde
s'intéresse à la prison il faut que ça
dure ça dure les propos d'Élisabeth
Guigou seront prémonitoires si ce
reportage sur les prisons de Lyon permet
la construction d'un nouvel
établissement l'emballement médiatique
provoqué par le livre de Véronique
Vasseur va peu à peu s'essouffler et
avec lui la volonté de l'opinion de
faire évoluer les choses Marylise le
branchu qui succède en octobre 2000 à
Elisabeth Guigou va en faire les frais
je crois qu'on avait ce qu'on appelle
horriblement parce que je déteste la
violence une fenêtre de tir mais ça a
été très court malheureusement très
court le fait d'avoir les deux
assemblées parlementaires
complètement convaincu à l'unanimité
c'était un sujet ouvrait quand même
formidable boulevard qui sait refermé en
novembre à peu près lorsque Jacques
Chirac ayant fait son discours sur la
sécurité au 14 juillet 2001
j'ai réuni à nouveau les parlementaires
de droite et de gauche ensemble pour
leur demander si tout le monde était
bien d'accord pour continuer sur le
consensus et je me souviens de Madame
Boutin me disant compte tenu d'ouverture
de la campagne présidentielle et des
mots employés par le Président de la
République ce sera plus possible et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quelques
années plus tard
il s'est passé que les députés les mêmes
qui avaient fait ce rapport indigné et
outré ont voté des lois extrêmement
répressives qui ont envoyé de plus en
plus de gens en prison totalement
incohérents on s'apprête à construire
5000 places de prison de plus on enferme
toujours plus on enferme des gens qui
sont des malades mentaux qui n'ont rien
à faire en prison
c'est la prise de conscience est très
vite retombée mais je pense que les
normes service de ce livre aura été de
provoquer ce débat malheureusement ça
fait le fonctionnement de la machine
médiatique il faut qu'il y ait un drame
ou un événement grave pour qu'on
s'intéresse vraiment au fond du sujet
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une prise de tâches
d'un témoignage fort ou d'image choc la
prison passionne mais qu'en est-il
lorsqu'il ne s'y passe rien pourquoi est
si compliqué de relater le quotidien
carcéral
[Musique]
après voilà comme on dit l'être humain
s'adapte à tout
on s'y fait
pas qui qui se bourre de cacher il y en
a qui moi j'ai pris l'option sport quoi
avec le sport que j'ai vécu tout ça ce
documentaire réalisé en 2007 par Martin
Blanchard pour Canal+ suit des détenus
avant et après leur sortie de prison il
aura nécessité un an et demi de travail
un délai qui s'explique en grande partie
par la difficulté à obtenir des
autorisations de tournage la première
des nombreuses contraintes inhérentes à
la présence d'une caméra en prison
lorsque j'ai tourné avec les détenus
interdiction d'aborder les faits et par
ailleurs on est en permanence avec un
surveillant qui nous accompagne bon
parfois c'est des choses qui se
négocient quand on est seul à seul en
cellule mais théoriquement il y a
toujours un surveillant qui est avec
nous les tournages se font aussi
toujours dans des créneaux horaires bien
particuliers dans des lieux déterminés
et puis comme il y a toujours cette
contrainte de sécurité des endroits on
ne peut pas filmer des moments où on ne
peut pas filmer c'est aussi
l'opportunité pour l'émission
pénitentiaire de visionner le sujet une
fois qu'il est fini pour s'assurer que
dans nos images il n'y ait pas
d'éléments qui puisse nuire après à la
sécurité du personnel
surveillance c'est quelque chose qui
peut se comprendre mais c'est aussi un
prétexte tout trouvé pour la mission
pénitentiaire pour pouvoir visionner les
films avant diffusion a priori c'est un
droit de regard mais après
pénitentielles aussi beaucoup de
ressources pour éventuellement faire
pression journaliste ne peuvent pas
rentrer filmer le quotidien sur une
assez longue durée quand il rentre d'une
façon très cadrée les questions sont
pratiquement préparées à l'avance les
détenus qui interrogent sont triés à
l'avance
éventuellement si l'administration
n'apprécie pas ses coupé donc c'est pas
la faute de la presse c'est-à-dire que
la presse ne peut montrer que ce qu'on
lui laisse voir il y a une certaine
routine qui s'est installée de la part
des journalistes parce qu'ils ont aussi
compris comment marche l'administration
pénitentiaire et ça serait bien que il y
a pas d'autres moyens de tourner en
prison que d'avoir l'accord et puis on
n'a pas envie d'être blacklisté c'est
tout le problème du compromis c'est à
dire que à un moment donné on souhaite
on est en prison et
on sait qu'on peut le faire que si ces
conditions-là sont sont
respectés et admises par les par les
rédactions moi je pense qu'il faut pas
le faire pas dans ces conditions pas
dans ces conditions
c'est une erreur
pourquoi l'administration pénitentiaire
semble-t-elle si fermée nous avons posé
la question à trois hommes qui
connaissent parfaitement son
fonctionnement
avocat pénaliste Thierry Lévy est engagé
depuis longtemps dans la cause
pénitentiaire il a d'ailleurs présidé
durant quatre ans l’observatoire
international des prisons Ahmed Luma
c'est lui est surveillant depuis
quelques années il est responsable du
syndicat CGT pénitentiaire en
Île-de-France enfin Pierre Botton reste
sans doute l'un des détenus les plus
médiatiques des années 90 depuis qu'il
est sorti de prison il s'est engagé dans
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
prisonniers
la communication c'est pas de
communication
je parle pas de ce qui me concerne
puisque moi je voulais je suis un peu il
m'appelle l'électron libre donc voilà je
suis électron libre mais
la pénitentiaire c'est comme l'armée
vous savez on appelle l'armée la grande
muette la pénitentielle la petite muette
oui non aucun intérêt à vous montrer
un quartier sur Fresnes ou sur Paris la
santé vous avez des rats qui sont aussi
gros que des champs ça c'est notre pass
à la télé ce qu'on montre à la télé
c'est un bel établissement avec avec des
beaux barreaux des belles cellules avec
des écrans plats voilà ça c'est pour
dire voilà la France écoutez il reste
avec la dignité humaine l'administration
présidentielle est très frileux elle a
peur qu'on parle d'elle elle elle veut
surtout pas qu'on parle d'elle et elle
communique donc très mal le chauffe
exception
elle elle est très consciente elle aussi
que le discours qu'elle pourrait tenir
ne serait pas entendu et par conséquent
elle choisit le silence le mensonge
l'hypocrisie
[Musique]
pénitentiaire le double de l'année
précédente et pourtant il reste des no
man's land journalistiques dans les
prisons des endroits coquins reportage
autorisés n'a jamais pu filmer en 2007
les caméras de M6 sont pu rester six
mois dans la maison d'arrêt d'Amiens
toutes les portes l'auront été ouvertes
toutes ou presque est-ce qu'on peut nous
y aller en promenade
ça vous pose problème que vous aviez
dans la cour
on sait pas ce qui peut se passer
malgré de nombreuses demandes nous ne
serons pas autorisés à entrer en
promenade il y a des choses de toute
façon qu'on a effectivement qu'on ne
peut pas montrer comme par principe de
sécurité la cour est un milieu
potentiellement dangereux bah une équipe
de tournage ne descendra pas dans la
cour de la même manière d'ailleurs que
les surveillants
ne sont pas présents dans les cours donc
rendre compte de la réalité d'une cour
de prison bah effectivement c'est pas
possible ou alors c'est les images qui
viennent de la prison comme ça c'est
fait pour dans le canal spécial les
images tournées de l'intérieur c'est
effectivement la seule manière de
montrer certaines réalités fin 2008 le
site internet du monde diffuse des
extraits d'une vidéo tournée
illégalement par des détenus de
Fleury-Mérogis quelques semaines plus
tard le magazine Envoyé Spécial achète
ces images et en réalise un document de
40 minutes
ils ont fait passer une petite caméra
derrière les barreaux et pendant 8 mois
ils ont tout filmé tout ce que nous avec
nos caméras journalistes nous ne pouvons
pas vous montrer pour la première fois
les téléspectateurs ont accès au
quotidien des détenus
oh regarde regarde
cette merde il n'y a pas de vitres à la
fenêtre
tu comprends quelque chose ou quoi tu es
ma grosse
image était extrêmement fortes c'est
effectivement l'une des premières fois
qu'on voyait réellement la vie des
détenus dans une prison française on
entend régulièrement tout un tas
d'études de rapport disant que les
conditions des tensions sont très
compliquées quand que la France est l'un
des pays les les plus en retard en
Europe pour les conditions de détention
des prisonniers là on avait
effectivement clairement sous les yeux
véritablement le problème de des douches
qui sont bouchées des toilettes qui sont
bouchées d'une prison qui est quasiment
une poubelle je crois savoir qu'en haut
lieu la Chancellerie ça a pas vraiment
plu parce que on se dit déjà tiens
comment une caméra puis échapper la
vigilance des surveillants c'est assez
étonnant et puis surtout ça ça dénoncé
c'était quand même des images qui
dénonçaient une situation qui est
franchement inacceptable aujourd'hui
quoi et pour la première fois les
téléspectateurs français ont accès à la
cour d'une prison dans la cour les
prisonniers sont livrés à eux-mêmes
loin et un endroit échappe totalement à
la vue du mirador il s'agit du préau un
recoin sombre au fond de la cour ficelle
et Hugo retrouve quand un homme se fait
subitement prendra parti
ça nous permet aussi de voir
l'incohérence du discours qu'on peut
tenir administration le ministère quand
il vous montre des établissements des
vitrines flambeau neuf où tout va bien
avec des cellules individuelles où tout
est propre et quand vous voyez ce qui
était filmé par les détenus à Fleury
vous voyez que c'est complètement à mon
appât le jour où ces images ont été
diffusées ce quartier de Fleury-Mérogis
qui était dans un état lamentable était
fermé depuis plusieurs mois pour une
rénovation complète donc nous le jour où
ces images ont été diffusées on n'a pas
dit que c'était un trucage un montage et
que c'était une falsification de la
vérité on a simplement dit évidemment
que cet état n'était pas correct c'est
la raison pour laquelle ça fait
plusieurs mois que l'établissement est
fermé et en cours de rénovation donc
nous prenons nous avons pris nos
responsabilités
Catherine tambrun et commissaire de
l'exposition prison l'impossible
photographie qui s'est tenu au musée
Carnavalet à Paris pour elle la
pénitentiaire se retrouve confrontée à
un véritable paradoxe
les images qui vont sortir maintenant
c'est des images faites par les détenus
donc il y a quelque chose de tout à fait
paradoxal a laissé finalement sortir
uniquement les photos des gens qui sont
leurs opposants évidemment naturellement
par essence et de ne pas autoriser un
photographe à photographier la prison
donc pour l'instant on est entre deux on
a d'un côté l'administration qui
communique sur des images oui très
propre de prison moderne etc et puis de
l'autre côté on a les images des détenus
qui nous renvoient les qui vont
photographier même deux trois chiffons
dans le coin d'un mur pour montrer que
c'est ça etc et donc du coup ils vont
avoir qu'un seul discours donc c'est
très paradoxal je sais même pas si ils
se sont posés la question cette là mais
il n'y a pas qu'en France que les
détenus décident parfois de se
substituer aux journalistes aux
États-Unis
Omar Broadway a réussi à faire entrer
une caméra dans sa cellule de la prison
de Northern States le résultat un film
de deux heures qui fera le tour du monde
là aussi c'était effectivement la
réalité de la prison filmée de
l'intérieur avec une caméra cachée donc
là on voyait effectivement pas forcément
l'état déplorable de la prise américaine
en question mais plutôt les brutalités
des surveillants des des humiliations au
quotidien un vrai problème quoi qui
entoure les détenus et ça te permettait
aussi de dénoncer c'est quand même ça
qui est important
[Musique]
alors est-ce vraiment compliqué pour un
journaliste de pénétrer dans une prison
française nous avons voulu faire le test
après deux mois d'attente nous avons
obtenu un rendez-vous auprès du service
communication de l'administration
pénitentiaire expliquant que nos délais
sont courts et que notre sujet concerne
les rapports entre prison et médias on
nous propose un tournage en moins d'une
semaine au nouveau centre pénitentiaire
de Rennes un centre synov que les
détenus ne sont même pas encore arrivés
Jérôme arnois le directeur nous fera
donc la visite de cette prison sans
prisonnier je vais prendre vous savez
les fameux trousseaux de visite si je
peux les avoir pour accéder un peu
partout merci je compare toujours
l'ouverture d'une prison maintenant un
peu comme un
un Airbus avant son premier vol
commercial il faut s'assurer que tout
fonctionne et pour s'assurer que tout
fonctionne il faut se mettre en dans la
réalité du quotidien donc nos procédures
à 85% elles sont elles deviennent
quasiment identiques au jour où les
détenus vont arriver
alors on est ici dans dans l'atrium
qui est un lieu on va dire un peu de
Carrefour de circulation et puis ici on
a le quartier arrivant donc tout détenu
qui arrive passent sept jours dans dans
ce quartier et puis là on va se on va
aller sur les parloirs
ça permet de casser un peu les séries
américaines parce que dans la dans la
représentation de beaucoup de gens un
parloir c'est une vitre ou un grillage
entre les deux et c'est tout sauf ça
puisque c'est voilà c'est un lieu où les
gens se rencontrent et ils peuvent se
toucher physiquement quoi l'image
caricaturale de nos prisons elle
effectivement dû à la fois aussi
américaine
à une volonté sans doute d'en rajouter
quelque part pour en faire encore
peut-être plus prison et puis aussi
quand même il faut le dire souvent une
volonté des médias de plutôt filmer une
vieille prison parce que ça fait plus
prison et puis ça fait voilà plutôt que
d'aller faire des images dans une prison
récente ou les conditions des tensions
qu'on veuille ou non faut quand même
bien reconnaître qu'elle s'améliore le
sentiment que j'ai c'est qu'à un moment
donné les médias veulent s'intéresser à
des choses qui comme si quand c'est
nouveau et que ça fonctionne pas trop
mal que c'est moins intéressant que le
truc qui est vêtu c'était où on peut
apporter beaucoup de critiques quoi
voilà
la visite se poursuit avec la découverte
d'un centre médical dernier
avec cabinet dentaire ou radiologie un
peu plus loin la salle polyvalente et un
terrain de foot synthétique les
nouvelles prisons aiment communiquer sur
ce confort moderne un confort souvent
jugé très relatif et superficiel par
leur détracteurs qui leur reprochent
avant tout leur éloignement des villes
et leur déshumanisation elle a encore
c'est un peu la schizophrénie médiatique
parfois ou on finit par des fois avoir
des articles où on finit par regretter
les prisons il y avait les rats ou les
prisons donc il faut un moment donné
quand même il faut arrêter d'être
démagos et de vouloir en permanence
critiquer ce qui est fait quoi
[Musique]
bonjour ça va
et puis alors on a
il y a 32 chaînes puisque maintenant il
y a que la TNT il y a Canal+ Canalsat
donc on a la télé quelque chose de très
important quoi et histoire de match par
exemple le sport à la télévision
la Coupe du Monde est un effet très
apaisant dans les prisons
je pense qu'encore plein de gens qui
sont surpris qu'un détenus puissent
avoir la télévision aux cellule certains
vont dire oui mais moi mon fils je loue
une chambre à la Cité universitaire et
il a même pas la douche en sachant quoi
il a la douche sur le palier encore et
c'est pas plus grand parce que je suis
plus combien ça fait une chambre de
citéu mais ça peut être 10 mètres carrés
maximum donc on est sur une superficie
équivalente
mais bon moi je rappelle toujours
d'abord qu'on faut comparer c'est
comparable ici on est dans une prison on
a beau avoir la télévision et la douche
c'est quand même l'enfermement et faire
que la porte se ferme à un moment donné
l'individuel chaîne satellite à 18 euros
par mois emplacement pour un
réfrigérateur en 2009 plus de 4500
détenus ont échangé leur vieille cellule
pour une nouvelle prison bénéficiant de
ses confort la pénitence irait
consciente que montrer ses améliorations
risque d'être mal perçu par l'opinion
dans les premières années de
Fleury-Mérogis en 1970 par image
évoquait déjà un Hilton pénitentiaire
depuis l'image de la prison fait le
grand écart entre 4 chaud ou hotel 4
étoiles
ce qui complique la manière de
communiquer c'est ce sont les deux
extrêmes entre ceux qui disent les
détenus sont mieux lotis sont les hôtels
4 étoiles ils ont la télévision en plus
certains en emploi et puis ceux qui
disent la prison et l'école de la
récidive et l'école du crime tout cela
est faux tout cela est faux parce que
c'est caricatural ce qui est étonnant
dans cette dans ce dilemme dans cette
contradiction c'est qu'on la retrouve
déjà au 19e siècle il y a eu une très
bonne ouvrage de Dominique Khalifa
sur la prison à Katsu qui reprend des
coupures de presse de la moitié du XIXe
siècle où certains journaux déplorent
les bonnes conditions des tensions en
disant mais regardez c'est détenus c'est
criminels c'est des vacances ils peuvent
prendre un bain une fois par semaine
alors que la plupart des gens des bonnes
gens dans leur maison dans leurs
appartements n'ont même pas accès à
l'eau au courant faut pas se leurrer en
fait quand on parle de la prison et même
quand on fait des films dessus on a
quand même l'impression qu'au
probablement de globalement prêcher dans
le désert parce que parce que les gens
s'en foutent malgré tout l'immense
majorité des gens considère que les gens
qui sont en prison ont ce qu'il méritent
et plus les conditions détention sont
dures après tout ils l'ont bien mérité
[Musique]
d'autant plus difficile de sensibiliser
l'opinion au sort des détenus que ces
derniers sont les grands absents des
reportages et même lorsqu'ils sont
présents ils sont systématiquement
masqués en prison c'est la loi s'arrête
ça s'arrête au mur de la prison après
c'est une autre loi qui est là quelque
part c'est presque la loi du talion
quand on arrive en prison
la loi pénitentiaire de 2009
officialisent ce qui était un simple
usage jusqu'à lors un détenu ne peut
apparaître un visage découvert devant
une caméra et ce même si les d'accord
deux raisons le respect des victimes et
la protection du prisonnier lui-même
il y a une règle absolue sur laquelle
vraiment de transige pas c'est le
respect de l'anonymat du détenu un
détenu c'est une personne qui est privée
de ses libertés qui n'a pas forcément
conscience des conséquences que peuvent
avoir la levée de son anonymat donc nous
souhaitons préserver l'anonymat des
détenus Dominique Perben a été garde des
sceaux dans le gouvernement Raffarin
pour lui aussi flouter un détenu comme
on dit dans les médias c'est avant tout
dans son intérêt je pense qu'il faut
faire très très attention parce que un
détenu à un moment donné peut se dire
j'ai intérêt à passer à la télé je
passerai un message etc mais la vie
continue derrière je veux dire attention
par définition une femme ou un homme qui
est en prison et dans une situation de
fragilité psychologique et je pense
qu'il faut il faut faire attention moi
peut-être qu'à un moment j'aurais voulu
quand j'étais incarcéré ou quand j'ai
fait ma TS vous voyez pouvoir parler et
aujourd'hui je serai fou qui a une image
comme ça qui je suis très très heureux
qui est aucune image de moi en prison
donc je pense que ça c'est préserver les
gens contre contre eux-mêmes et une
mission pénitentiaire se comporte avec
les détenus toujours de la même manière
c'est une matière très
surprotectrice et en fait on déni au
détenu en permanence
leur capacité de manifester leur libre
arbitre la détention normalement c'est
uniquement une privation liberté mais
uniquement au travers de ce droit à
l'image on se rend bien compte que c'est
beaucoup plus qu'une privation de
liberté de mouvement je pense qu'il faut
avoir l'honnêteté d'expliquer à
l'intéressé voilà ok
qu'il l'assume parce que voilà il s'est
sur un coup de tête ils sont ils sont
ils sont en prison dans une dans un
contexte particulier
avoir cette explication là qu'elle soit
très claire à partir du moment où
l'intéressait d'accord effectivement je
crois que le temps du foutage il est
terminé
une fois demandé de témoigner dans un
reportage qui se faisait dans une prison
où j'étais mais il n'est pas question
que je témoigne flouté ou je témoignais
un visage découvert parce que j'assumais
ce que je voulais dire flouté j'aurais
l'air de me cacher donc je trouve que
c'est parfaitement hypocrite stupide
ça contribue à biaiser la vérité et ça
ne sert à rien on connaît très bien tous
les problèmes de tout ce qui était moins
anonyme
dénonciation anonyme le mot anonymat
finalement j'ai toujours un doute un
doute sur la véracité à d'autres sur le
netteté de la personne mais le deuxième
doute au-delà de cette de cette
sincérité de cette honnêteté c'est tout
simplement l'empathie ça veut dire que
on est empathique et on peut avoir des
sentiments pour on peut essayer de
comprendre quelqu'un ou essayer de se
rapprocher de la situation à quelqu'un
quand il y a peu de distance entre les
entre les personnes il faut vraiment que
le témoignage soit très fort s'il est
flouté pour qu'il soit réellement
entendu
la télé c'est l'image l'image c'est des
c'est des regards
un floutage effectivement ça perturbe
grandement le la portée d'un discours
c'est pas c'est pas la même chose un
petit peu ce qui a été fait au moment où
on a décidé
qu'il fallait pas montrer les gens me
dotés
[Musique]
parce que c'était contraire il disait
humaine de lui montrer menotté alors on
peut considérer que c'est contraire
c'est humaine de montrer les visages de
gens qui sont détenus alors qu'en
réalité ce qui est contraire résisté
humaine c'est la détention ce qui est
contraire même c'est les menottes c'est
pas le c'est pas le fait de les
photographier ou les filmer c'est pas la
réalité qui choque c'est l'image de la
réalité
[Musique]
filmer un détenu à visage découvert
c'est possible mais ce n'est pas en
France que ça se passe
[Musique]
direction Namur en Belgique wallonne à
quelques mètres du centre-ville la
prison et ses 204 détenus
le bâtiment a été construit en 1876 ce
qui en fait l'un des établissements
pénitenciers les plus anciens du royaume
c'est ici que nous rencontrons Dimitri
un détenu en fin de peine il nous
accueille dans sa cellule très
confortable d'abord il y a l'ordinateur
la télévision primordiale pour garder
l'émission sur les animaux tous mes
cours sur les étagères cours de cuisine
il y a des des cours d'anglais il y a
des cours d'informatique et d'ingestion
la guitare apportant des cours aussi qui
ont été donnés jusqu'à la prison de
Namur les cours de guitare ça c'est
génial c'est le genre de choses quand on
a l'extérieur qu'on veut faire qu'on ne
fait jamais on n'a jamais le temps on a
plein d'autres choses à faire des
courses chez Cora etc ici c'est le
calendrier et voyez que chaque jour
très déterminé rouge
et alors c'est étonnant j'ai pas barré
le 10 vous voyez je suis en train de
m'acclimater Dimitri n'a pas hésité une
seconde lorsqu'on lui a demandé de
témoigner à visage découvert pour lui le
floutage est une hérésie je pense que
c'est un petit démocratique si quelqu'un
a envie de s'exprimer à visage découvert
il a le droit de le faire c'est pas
parce que dans une période de sa vie il
a un statut de détenu qui perd les
droits simplement à s'exprimer et à
s'exprimer évidemment au visage
découvert puisque il persistait signe
quelque part avec le visage découvert
tout ce que vous pouvez dire un visage
couvert c'est comme si vous ne le dites
pas
même discours de la part de la
directrice de l'établissement Valérie
Lebrun en Belgique si un détenu a donné
son accord il peut témoigner un visage
découvert et Madame la Directrice trouve
sa totalement normale la privation
liberté ce n'est que la privation de
liberté ça reste un citoyen comme un
autre donc si il est d'accord de parler
à visage découvert devant les caméras je
ne vois pas de quel droit je pourrais
lui interdire donc ça me semble en tout
cas en effet une à l'abus de pouvoir que
je ne comprends pas très bien d'un point
de vue légal par rapport à notre
législation en tout cas comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le justifier mais le
floutage n'est pas la seule exception
belge ici on nous ouvre n'importe quelle
porte et même celle des cellules les
plus vétustes
donc vous avez ici les cellules de Namur
donc vous voyez qu'il y a deux matelas
qui sont prévus étant donné que
régulièrement ils sont à trois
avec à une petite toilette et un coin un
évier avec de l'eau froide et donc il
faut compter qui sont 22h sur 24 dans
une cellule comme ceci quand ils sont en
préventif puisqu'ils ont droit à deux
préaux point la télévision est
importante ça a l'air beaucoup la
télévision la télévision est
pratiquement constamment allumée et il
faut savoir également que c'est souvent
source de conflit parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas regarder les mêmes les mêmes
reportages et c'est souvent source de
tension au moment des matchs de foot
[Musique]
en Belgique non seulement on ne cache
pas le délabrement mais en plus on en
fait de l'art
vraiment qui ont été prises à différents
moments qui montrent évidemment les
conditions de détention aussi parce que
c'est dans l'objectif aussi de
sensibiliser le public quel est
l'intérêt pour vous de montrer ces
images au grand public tout simplement
parce que je pense que dans un état
démocratique le degré démocratie et
s'évalue justement à la façon dont on
traite les personnes incarcérées et
qu'il est tout à fait indigne de notre
siècle et de d'un État comme la Belgique
d'avoir encore des conditions de
détention qui datent du XIXe siècle ce
n'est pas normal et ce n'est pas humain
ça permet de sensibiliser de l'opinion
publique ça permet aussi de sensibiliser
le monde politique pour qu'on puisse
donner des conditions détention mais
aussi s'il y a quand même à le souligner
aussi les conditions de travail qui soit
adéquates par rapport aux normes de
sécurité qui doivent exister à l'heure
actuelle c'est à dire que les images
parfois pour vous peuvent être une arme
pour convaincre les politiques de vous
donner des moyens par exemple bien sûr
tout à fait autre différence de taille
en Belgique les délais pour obtenir les
autorisations de tournage qui sont
considérablement raccourcis
pour comprendre comment et surtout
pourquoi nous nous rendons à Bruxelles
dans les bureaux de la direction
pénitentiaire belge
Laurent SEMPO gère la communication des
prisons belges c'est lui qui reçoit les
demandes des journalistes et voilà
comment ça se passe pour les
informations en elle-même donc ça c'est
les interviews et les interviews en
elle-même ça se fait sur le moment même
donc les demandes de reportage dans un
cas classique il faut compter c'est dans
la semaine en règle générale alors si je
prends maintenant un exemple j'ai reçu
mardi passé une demande d'une
journaliste suédoise ça va partir
aujourd'hui au président du comité de
direction j'aurai en principe
l'autorisation aujourd'hui ou demain et
donc demain la journaliste aura sa
réponse
positive pour aller faire un reportage à
la prison de forêt donc si on résume le
délai aurait été de combien de temps à
peu près une semaine mais à se montrer
aussi ouverte avec la presse alors que
beaucoup de pays d'Europe restent
frileux sur la question la Belgique ne
risque-t-elle pas de devenir le centre
d'attraction de tous les journalistes en
mal d'images c'est déjà arrivé
clairement que qu'on ressentait bien
qu'une demande d'autorisation était
introduite en Belgique parce que dans
leur pays elle avait été refusé
on sent bien qu'il trouve des excuses
pour dire que c'est intéressant qui
s'intéresse à la situation en Belgique
ce genre de choses là et dans ce cas là
ça ce sont des reportages qui sont
refusés
l'ouverture à la presse n'a pas toujours
été la règle au contraire ça ne fait que
quelques années depuis la Belgique se
cherche parce qu'à accepter des projets
de documentaires ambitieux on frôle
parfois l'émission de télé-réalité c'est
le cas de leven Hulpe aide à Louvain en
français les équipes de la télévision
flamandes une devait réaliser un
documentaire sur la création d'une pièce
de théâtre dans la prison de Louvain
alors le principe donc c'était de suivre
en fait les détenus de cette pièce de
théâtre en tout cas ceux qui l'ont
accepté
pendant toute la durée des répétitions
qui ont duré trois mois c'est pour ça
que le temps de présence était trois
mois et par conséquent ici on montre
aussi on montre la vie quotidienne de la
prison les états d'âmes et les
sentiments des détenus qui participent
mais aussi alors toute une série de
répétitions du théâtre et pendant le
dernier épisode il y a la représentation
qui
qui est filmé en fait mais à l'antenne
on a pu découvrir un générique digne
d'une série télé une musique qui appuie
le suspense ou la tension et même des
caméras confessions en cellule
[Musique]
en fait c'est le feuilleton de la vie en
prison en tout cas dans la vie de la
prison ici en question voilà là le
détenu va être libéré donc il est en
train d'attendre d'être libéré
il tient plus en place ce qui est assez
logique
et là vous avez pensé aux problèmes des
victimes notamment dans ce cas-ci non
tout comme on ne cache pas l'état
parfois insalubre des cellules dans ce
programme on montre tout ça a été filmé
sans aucun tabou
puisque on va même jusqu'à filmer un
détenu qui est en train de se rouler un
joint dans sa cellule ça a été montré ça
fait beaucoup de choc mais c'est la
réalité il y a de la drogue en prison et
on sait
et ça ça me gêne pas de le montrer c'est
à dire que c'est gênant de le montrer
mais c'est la réalité la direction
pénitentiaire belge ne tarit pas
d'éloges sur l'émission en reconnaissant
tout de même que ce programme est plus
qu'un simple documentaire c'est vraiment
le plus loin qu'on a été c'est à dire
qu'on est de nouveau à la limite du
balancier entre le documentaire sur la
vie en prison et la téléréalité
mais la télé-réalité en prison ne
concerne pas que la Belgique nous sommes
en Espagne et ici les détenus chantent
ça s'appelle el Koro de la Carcel le
cœur de la prison et il s'agit ni plus
ni moins que d'une nouvelle star sous
écrou
[Musique]
je pense que c'était assez flatteur pour
un point d'administration pénitentiaire
espagnole montre aussi qu'il y a une
certaine ouverture d'esprit qu'on peut
faire entrer des caméras qu'on peut
faire participer les détenus à un
programme oui bien sûr c'est assez
flatteur bien sûr c'est plutôt positif
pour l'administration pénitentiaire bien
sûr évidemment la prison spectacle en
télé-réalité mais aussi dans les clips
la publicité et les séries de Prison
Break house les barreaux fascinent
à la télévision américaine qui montre
clairement le quotidien d'une prison et
on voit que c'est une prison moderne
c'est
ultra moderne tout est propre tout est
nickel c'est du béton c'est de l'inox
c'est magnifique c'est formidable
parmi les séries télé bien avant Prison
Break la pionnière du genre s'appelait
ose diffusée à partir de 1997 sur la
chaîne câbler age bio aux États-Unis et
sur Série Club et M6 en France la série
montrait un univers carcéral sans
concession
[Musique]
c'était une série extrêmement forte
c'est interdit au moins une saison quand
même faut s'en faut se rappeler de ça
quand c'est passé sur M6 c'était
effectivement extrêmement violent il y
avait un climat psychologique aussi de
d'humiliation de certains détenus
vis-à-vis des autres c'était parfois
aussi très sexuel parce qu'il y avait
clairement montré aussi qu'en prison ben
voilà il y a des relations sexuelles qui
sont pas consenties qui sont imposés il
y a des viols clairement il y a des il y
a des meurtres il y a des choses comme
ça enfin c'est il y a la drogue
également qui était très très présente
dans oz
[Musique]
quand on voit le clip de Lady Gaga c'est
plus espèce d'univers fantasmatique j'ai
envie de dire c'est vrai que quand on
voit des des fictions érotiques ça se
passe souvent dans des prisons pour
femmes avec de pauvres prisonnières qui
sont livrés à la merci le matonne ça
peut faire rêver ça peut faire fantasmer
certains
je crois que les détenus qui regardent
ça sur leur petite télé dans leur
cellules en France où ils sont trois ou
quatre dans 9 mètres carrés je suis pas
certain que eux ça les fasse si rire ou
sourire que ça en tout cas ça les fait
pas rêver ça c'est sûr parfois en
revanche la fiction permet de montrer ce
que les journalistes ne peuvent pas
filmer en 2006 Bernard George réalise
pour Canal+ un documentaire sur les
conditions de vie des détenus un film à
charge et assumer comme tel son titre la
honte de la République les Bernard
Georges n'obtiendra jamais
l'autorisation de tourner en prison
au début il y a eu une possibilité et
ils ont envoyé dans une espèce de prise
en modèle avec des gamins modèles des
petites formidables qui sera insérés
tout ça moi les premiers rush que j'ai
vu c'est mort de rire donc j'ai dit
c'est pas sérieux donc la demander des
établissements particuliers et puis à
partir de là ça a été fini donc on a eu
non surtout donc on a fait un décor et
puis on a mis trois comédiens à
l'intérieur et c'est c'est tout à fait
spectaculaire de promiscuité quoi
[Musique]
oui cellulaire il y a quelque chose de
la perception de la promiscuité des
odeurs du bruit qui se passe
c'est quoi ce bordel
c'est presque mathématique c'est la
surface et les gens que tu mets à
l'intérieur mais qui est obligé de faire
ça il faut quand même montrer
[Musique]
pour dénoncer montrer pour faire évoluer
les choses également parfois les médias
ne sont pas considérés comme des
adversaires par l'administration
pénitentiaire ou les politiques mais
plutôt comme des alliés
[Musique]
nous partons pour les établissements de
vidsville à quelques kilomètres de Berne
en Suisse ce matin la presse est invité
par le secrétaire d'État français à la
justice Jean-Marie Bocquel a visité une
prison ouverte autrement dit une ferme
ici les détenus sont libres pas de
barreaux mais à la place des chevaux des
cochons et des journalistes même s'il
s'agit d'une prison aujourd'hui tout est
fait pour faciliter le travail des
médias la visite se déroule d'ailleurs
dans la bonne humeur avec jeu de mots au
passage c'est un problème monsieur peut
dire tous mes projets sont détruits
cette bonne ambiance n'est pas du au
hasard pour Jean-Marie Bocquet qui
aimerait voir émerger ce type de
détention en France c'est à la fois une
manière d'occuper le devant de la scène
médiatique mais aussi de préparer le
terrain c'est un sujet qui doit
rencontrer
l'adhésion de de l'opinion publique ou
d'une partie de l'opinion publique ce
qui est le moment venu facilitera
également le la tâche parce que il y a
tellement de prévention par rapport à
tout ce qui relève du monde carcéral de
la prison voir d'une prison sans
barreaux vous imaginez dont on peut
s'évader et donc je crois que c'est par
le le témoignage de ce qui existe et de
ce qui fonctionne qu'on peut faire
reculer ces idées reçues et faciliter
donc le moment venu les bonnes décisions
pour que il y ait davantage de prison de
ce type en France d'ailleurs les choses
semblent évoluer à son arrivée à la
Chancellerie en juin 2009 Michel
Alliot-Marie a créé des stages en
immersion des journalistes peuvent
passer de 4 à 48 heures dans une prison
pour RMC Christophe Bordet à séjourner
deux jours à la maison d'arrêt de l'île
segdin il a apprécié cette expérience à
une exception près et les règles du jeu
c'était que on faisait de la radio mais
qu'on ne pouvait pas emmener d'appareils
pour enregistrer quiconque qu'il était
pas question évidemment d'emmener une
caméra non plus
pire encore qu'il était préférable
d'avoir une bonne mémoire puisque il
était pas possible d'avoir un stylo et
un calepin
pour prendre des notes la caméra change
la prise de notes change enlève
certainement de la spontanéité dans les
interlocuteurs moi si on discute et que
je vois que vous prenez de notes je vais
beaucoup plus me maîtriser dans ma dans
mes paroles dans mon comportement si on
peut enregistrer forcément on a on a des
preuves quelque part de ce qui est dit
de ce qui et là la seule preuve que
l'auditeur va avoir c'est c'est c'est
celle du journaliste qui va raconter ce
qu'il a vécu c'est tout donc ça c'est un
vrai problème je trouve effectivement on
peut imaginer que ces stages d'immersion
au bout d'un an deux ans bah peut-être
qu'un jour il y a un bloc-notes qui va
glisser dans la main d'un journaliste et
que personne va rien lui dire et
peut-être que dans quelques années il y
aura aussi des caméras
peu à peu la prison s’ouvre journaliste
les efforts de la pénitentiaire sont
importants depuis quelques années mais
la méfiance prend encore trop souvent le
dessus on a peur de la réalité dans ce
pays c'est ça le problème on a peur de
la réalité dans ce pays voilà le jour où
on pourra en 24 heures rentrer avec une
caméra et filmer tout ce qu'on veut là
on aura fait un grand pas pour
transformer dans l'imaginaire des
Français l'idée qu'ils se font de leur
prison l'équilibre ça serait que tous
les médias puissent faire leur travail
comme ils font ailleurs dans le respect
de la déontologie dans le respect des
règles d'information de respect de la du
droit à la vie privée à l'image ainsi de
suite c'est vrai qu'en l'idéal pour de
simples raisons de bons fossements la
démocratie ce serait plus simple si on
avait un accès plus facile au mieux
carcérale mais je dirais en mieux
carcéral c'est peut-être pas la priorité
absolue et première de faciliter les
tournages une présence est une prison on
n'est pas non plus les rois du monde à
pouvoir entrer où on veut quand on veut
cette volonté de d'ouverture aujourd'hui
elle existe parce que ma manifestement
c'est une institution qui a fait sa
propre évolution et que et qu'il faut
que ça sache il faut que ça se dise donc
les médias c'est quand même le meilleur
vecteur pour
apporter un déclic dans la tête de ceux
qui regardent la télé dans la tête de
ceux qui disent des journaux et ainsi de
maturité d'une société de montrer ses
prisons de montrer l'envers du décor en
quelque sorte et je pense que ce qui se
passe depuis un certain nombre d'années
de ce point de vue là est positif il y a
une passion une curiosité il y a une
volonté de traiter le sujet on est aussi
responsable de la désinformation si on
n'ouvre pas soi-même son lieu et bien on
laisse les médias raconter ce qu'ils ont
envie de raconter avec le peu
d'informations qu'ils ont
une institution qui a tendance à
fonctionner dans le secret
ce condamne
[Musique]